so our next speaker is sent from
University Delphi flask and keep tell us
about the logic of counting query
answers thanks so I'd like to thank all
of the everyone involved with the
organization of this works up in this
program for the opportunity to
participate in the speak today i'll talk
about joint work with stefan Mengel
who's working in france ok so I want to
just begin with an overview the initial
computational problem that will be
concerned with in this talk is sometimes
called query evaluation and we just want
to evaluate a formula on a finite
structure so we want to determine given
a formula in a finite structure the set
of assignments that satisfy the formula
over the structure and throughout the
talk I'll use this notation 5b to note
this set of assignments in this top 5
will always be a first order formula and
in fact we're going to focus on the
counting version of this problem which
is to determine the number of answers
again given these two things of formula
in a structure ok this is intractable in
general so just to be just to give a
concrete example at the formula is
something that might look like this so
in this problem we'd be given a formula
a structure which interprets the
relation symbols and we want to count
the number of assignments to the free
variables of the formula that satisfy
the formula on the structure ok so this
generalizes the model checking problem
which here i define to be the problem of
deciding if a sentence is satisfied by a
structure for we have that well the
empty assignment satisfies formula if
and only if sorry a sentence if and only
if is the app is an answer to a sentence
if and only if the sentence is true over
the struct the sentences throughout the
structure
okay so let's suppose that we have a
first-order formula in in our hands and
we're sort of interested in counting the
number of answers over maybe various
databases or structures be sort of the
motivating question for the socket I'll
elaborate on as we go is whether or not
there's sort of a good language or logic
in which we could express a useful
algorithms for computing the mapping
which takes us from a structure to the
number of answers for this first order
formula of interest and in this talk we
present such a logic which we call sharp
logic and sort of one application that
we envision is that it could serve as a
target language into which one could
compile first order in formulas of
interest and I'll elaborate this sort of
again more as we go but we sort of our
logic well enjoy and balance two
properties and the one hand it will be
sufficiently expressive to allow for the
direct expression of efficient
algorithms for this counting problem but
on the other hand it will enjoy a good
computability problem namely minimizing
a quantity called width will be what we
can do computer bleah ok so now I want
to say something about the background
for this talk ok so the counting query
answers problem is intractable in
general it's well known that if we just
restrict a problem to a single first
order formula the problem is tractable
and one of the things that we want to do
in this work is to try to identify types
of formulas which enjoy good
computational behavior tractable
behavior and the literature there's a
established way of sort of restricting
the general problem to try to study sort
of which formulas are well-behaved
namely we restrict the general problem
to a class of formulas so for every
single class of first sort of formulas
of the final accounting problem over
five to be this restricted version of
the general problem where the formula
must come from our class right so now
again we're just given a formula in a
structure but the formula has to come
from this particular class and we want
to perform the count ok so yeah so for
example we might ask for with
the first order formulas is this problem
tractable and from which is it not
Sookie Cassius has a question so as you
said you take that model checking but
you have two formulas part of the input
it's a you know it's you know you know
first order of chris's is zero but that
always part of the input is pspace
complete so I'm not sure which one
you're looking at some care what the
formulas part of the input yeah
performance part of the employer so
typically that's going to be pspace
complete even for a really weak language
he's got the times on the particular
classified right okay I'm gonna restrict
a general problem according to some
class fine right so restrictive single
crystal form unit but it'll eyes you
don't understand sorry what's this
capital so I could be a single to them
that it's easy yes exactly right hey
complexities till October giver for
County best buddies okay it's a phone
this fixed yet yeah it's your space
right but this is this is a way of sort
of interpolating between these two
extremes right the general of cases
where we take the cluster of all
formulas this is saying well we take
just a class with one formula we get
polynomial-time tractability and so this
is a way of sort of exploring the space
in between perhaps
okay so well it's been argued repeatedly
the literature that class call
complexity theory like notions like that
of polynomial time aren't totally
satisfactory in the study of query
evaluation for a typical scenario is the
evaluation of a small query or formula
on a big structure of database and the
sort of discrepancy between the two
parts of the input and asymmetry
suggests that maybe we could tolerate a
bad dependence on the query or formula
as long as we have a good dependence on
the structure and so there's a sort of
suitable complexity theoretic framework
for studying precisely this type of
situation parameterised complexity
theory where essentially we classify
problems up to allowing arbitrary
computation on the parameter I'll be a
bit more precise in the moment okay we
always take the query or the formula to
be the parameter following this
motivation okay so again this is our
sort of family of problems for every
class of formulas we have a counting
problem over Phi we want to maybe
understand which ones are tractable and
which ones are interactable and the
particular notion of tractability we use
is fixed parameter tractability so
here's a formulation we relax the notion
of polynomial time to to allow a
pre-processing in the formula right a
computable pre-processing so we say that
there just has to be some algorithm f
that that's a lot of pre process the
formula but then sort of after that
pre-processing in polynomial time we can
compute the desired value so right
particular app if I can just blow up the
formula exponentially or worse right so
we again we relax the new sub polynomial
time but just allowing this
pre-processing only on the parameter
which is the formula ok so in recent
work with Stefan we classified all
existential positive formulas I'll use
this notation just to indicate that we
restrict first-order logic according to
these connected so for any class of
existential positive formulas a bounded
arity we prove a dichotomy theorem we
saw that if some condition holds which
I'm not going to describe here then the
counting problem is tractable in the
sense that I just described and
otherwise we prove that the
the problem is not tractable unless an
unexpected collapse occurs and
parameterize complexity theory and so
this gives sort of a full dichotomy
theorem for at least four existential
positive formulas okay now I want to
talk about with so I think we've seen
this already this week by the width of a
first-order formula is the maximum
number of free variables overall sub
formulas of the formula it's a syntactic
measure of a formula may be sort of a
syntactic measure of complexity and
there's a sort of classic observation
that if we restrict model checking two
formulas of bounded with or bound the
number of variables then in fact it's
it's still in polynomial time right so
if we impose a bound k then model
checking a sentence with at most K on a
finite structure is polynomial time
tractable right user sort of do the
naive inductive evaluation okay so just
as a consequence of this observation we
can make another observation which is
that we get a very easily a sufficient
condition for model checking to be
inside fbt right now we can relax this
we say well if we have a this sort of
compilation algorithm f that passes from
every single sentence in our class 2a
logically equivalent sentence of bounded
with then this is going to be tractable
in the sense of parameterize complexity
right so again we just sort of relax
this condition instead of bounded with
we say well if we can computer bleep ass
two sentences abounded with then we're
also tractable in the sense of
parameterize complexity
okay so this was our observation and in
pass work we proved that for any class
of existential positive sentences if
model checking is tractable on the class
then this sufficient condition for
tractability is in fact necessary so
this sufficient condition is sort of the
only possible explanation for fixed
parameter tractability in this prep in
this particular context okay so here I
want to highlight perhaps a conceptual
point which is that like in our view
here first order logic is like playing
the role of a useful model of
computation right if you're not attract
ability at all we have tractability just
by sort of rewriting the sentences and
putting them into a good format right so
like maybe another way when I think of
this is that first order logic in some
sense sort of modular that's rewriting
contains the computational primitives
that we need to express these the
algorithms which win its attract ability
question here is a little I mean this
looks a lot to me like like for certain
fixed point which which of course has
abandoned with and the incentives you
can either uniformly compute that
formula using fixed point where you're
allowed to do it not uniformly is so
you're having more power than fix point
but is it really does that really need
it do you need to non-uniform unit
otherwise what he means by you know what
do you mean by non uniformity here 90
for me is going to ever far from thought
so what's our what's right so my
questions okay oh I'm going to compare
your approach to first trip plus please
fix point oh no brand new model skeptics
doesn't care before we left for
everything good size in the swamp phone
we have a cross of formulas right okay
we have an entire closet think of it as
a large infinite class of 14 once we're
saying that that well we have this sort
of this algorithm f that for any formula
or any sentence in our class can rewrite
it into a bounded variable sentence
right there's but that once it was for
all structure sizes yes yeah yeah
because cuz I thought I thought
everything is first order here right all
sentences are first order but I thought
you were using the kind of thing that
the cave variable data log this is by
counting the number of triangles you
have one sentence but ok ok I should
yeah sir bricks on the fact i could say
here that like in some sense logic is
playing too perhaps complementary roles
right on the one hand the computational
problems that were interested in our
phrase directly in terms of logic but on
the other hand somehow the algorithmic
solutions to these problems that were
looking at also seem to be phrased in
terms of logic module sort of in terms
of this rewriting of sentences ok so the
motivating question for the present work
is the following we wanted to know if
there was some sort of analogously use
for logic for accounting query answers
in which we could sort of express the
efficient algorithms given by our
dichotomy theorem right so in a certain
sense what we're asking for is some sort
of counting analog of founded with her
bounded variable logic which retains
sort of the good properties that we just
discussed and okay just to be like
completely clear about this just recall
that in model checking we have a
sentence in a structure we want to
decide if the sentence is true on the
structure of course this is a
propositional value right it's yes or no
in the counting answers question we're
given a formula in a structure
and we want to compute the number of
assignments that satisfy the formula in
the structure right so this is a
numerical value right so sort of mine
mmm criterion for logic is that we
should have some notion of sentence
where when we evaluated on a structure
it's going to give us a numerical value
and not just not merely a propositional
value okay so we're going to give such a
logic which we call sharp logic okay so
let me say some things about the
properties that are logic has okay every
single formula is going to have a set of
free variables if there are no free
variables we call formula sentence and
sort of the maybe the first most
relevant property is that once again if
we if we bound the width inside our new
logic which I haven't defined yet but
it's going to be the case that if we
bound the width then we still have that
evaluation can be done in polynomial
time all right and sort of the
sufficient we can now come up with a
sufficient condition for FB t as well
sort of analogous to our a sufficient
condition for model checking and for
this we need this definition which sort
of links our logic to the counting query
answers question will say that a
sentence in our logic sigh represents
the first order formula Phi if sort of
size sort of always tells us what
happens right so sigh is always going to
tell us when evaluated on be it's going
to give us this value the number of
answers to Phi all right and then sort
of just as before we get a sufficient
condition for fixed parameter
tractability right now we say well if
there's some algorithm which passes from
every single formula to a sharp
representation in our logic with bounded
with then the problem will be an FPT
right and sort of the reason for this is
just as before well you just apply to
this algorithm as sort of the
compilation and then you invoke this
observation which will evaluate the
resulting bounded with sentence in
polynomial time
okay so one of our main theorems is this
I showed this dichotomy theorem for
existential positive formulas and we
proved that on these classes this
condition is the exclusive explanation
for it for compatibility and
parameterizing complexity so we have
tractability at all according to our
dichotomy theorem we have tractability
by this sufficient condition or
differently this the sufficient
condition is in fact necessary at least
for problems of this form okay yeah I'm
going to do that or I'm going to do that
by an example here so here let's look at
a little example a tiny example we have
a formula just with two atomic formulas
v y VZ and we have relations C&F and
sort of the first thing we can do in
this logic is will be just what
so the first thing that we can do in
this logic is what we call casting which
means that we just apply see to some
first order formula and we get a formula
in our logic and okay let's let B be a
structure now to specify the semantics
of our logic we have to say for every
single structure and every single
formula and then every single assignment
of the free variables what the semantics
are right which is going to be a number
and so when we cast a formula we just
get 1 or 0 depending on whether or not
the structure in the assignments satisfy
the casted formula now we haven't a sort
of a quantifier which we call projection
and okay in this particular example a
projection will behave like this if we
take the this previous formula and we
project away the variable Y and then we
evaluate this on an assignment to V we
get the number of extensions of V of
this assignment the number of extensions
to Y which satisfies uvy right so again
this is says that well we fix a value
for V this is going to tell us the
number of extensions which satisfy sort
of this left part of the formula yeah we
can sort of do this for the other atomic
formula if we'd sort of project the way
the other casted version we get the
number of extensions for an assignment
to V we get the number of extensions
which satisfy sort of the the right this
right-hand part of the formula right and
now okay our logic has a multiplication
which just has the semantics that you
think it has it just will multiply the
values of the previous two quantities
and if you actually think about it this
is going to be precisely the number of
extensions to all the free variables
that satisfy Phi right because if we
sort of fix a value for V the other two
variables intuitively they behave
orthogonal right there's no constraint
or interaction between them right so
sort of with this we just project away
the remaining variable V we get a
representation of Phi right which sort
of always tells us the number of answers
right now this was a small example but
actually this formula has with to the
naive
representation here we'll have with
three and it turns out that in fact if
we had an instance that look like a tree
we could sort of apply this idea
inductively and no matter what the tree
look like get it you also get a
representation of with two and then we
can generalize this and say that well if
we had a graph which had bound the tree
which I tree with K we can in fact cook
up a representation sort of using
similar ideas of with k plus wine okay
so okay so this is just a very quick
summary of our logic we have this
casting which we saw we have projection
we can expand the number of free
variables we have multiplication and
addition and we also allow sort of
constants we assume that they're cooked
in to the logic of all integers in fact
ok now I'm going to talk about with
minimization so let's imagine that we
have some first sort of formula with
these three free variables a B and C and
let's define a new formula just by sort
of shuffling around the free variables
now of course in general these two
formulas are not going to be logically
equivalent but what is going to be true
is that they're always going to be
counting equivalent in the sense that
we're always going to they're always
going to return the same number of
answers when we evaluate them on any
finite structure right said we say that
two formulas are counting equivalent if
this holds right we always get the same
number of answers so we're able to
exactly characterize counting
equivalents in in primitive positive
logic so sort of without disjunction
just conjunction and existential
quantification and essentially what we
proved is that sort of this renaming of
variables and logical equivalents are
the only phenomena possible phenomena
behind counting equivalents and this
characterization in fact implies that
it's computable to the site if to
primitive positive formulas are counting
equivalent
okay so we're able to prove this this
theorem which gives sort of a good
computability property of our logic we
call this with minimization and this
says that there's some algorithm which
given any formula in our logic where we
only cast existential positive logic
outputs are logically equivalent formula
which has minimum width right so here's
maybe like a rough idea of how the
algorithm works basically first we take
each formula and we normalize it so that
basically it's the weighted sum of
primitive positive queries in fact we do
this using a the inclusion-exclusion
principle and okay then we can sort of
assume that the sides are coming in
equivalent by applying the algorithm of
the previous slide and then what we do
is we just sort of minimize each of
these primitive positive formulas
individually but in order to justify
this we have to somehow show that all
these primitive positive formulas really
are orthogonal to each other that they
don't sort of cancel out and so we prove
sort of what we call the independence
theorem which basically says that if we
have a non trivial linear combination of
primitive positive formulas like this
then we can always cook up a finite
structure such that this linear
combination doesn't cancel out 20
uniformly right so there's always some
finite structure on which this
combination will evaluate to a nonzero
value and okay I'm going to skip the
idea of the proof perhaps but yeah I can
discuss a consequence of this theorem so
let's just look at structures over some
some signature towel and for a given
structure a let's take the vector where
we have an entry for every single finite
structure and maps a structure be to the
number of homo morphisms from a right
now our theorem this independence
theorem implies like via the Chandra
Merlin correspondence that if we have
like any finite sequence of pairwise non
isomorphic struck
then in fact if we take these vectors
they're going to be linearly independent
I said right they really behavior
thuggin Utley from each other and a sort
of as an immediate corollary we obtained
that like two of these vectors are going
to be equal if and only if the original
structures are equal so these vectors
really characterize the original
structures and in fact this gives us an
exact dual to a classical theorem of low
bus Lobot sort of studied exactly the
dual vector so he said well take a
structure be and let's look at the
vector which maps of structure a to the
number of homomorphisms to be all right
so this is just the exact dual and he
proved sort of just the dual of this
corollary so sort of two of his vectors
are equivalent if and only if the
original two structures are isomorphic
ok so i know i went to wrap up so logics
with counting mechanisms have been
previously considered in a variety of
areas and one example is the counting
logic studied by environment and lander
and subsequently by many others and to
my understanding a typical motivation in
these areas is the desire to extend
first-order logic or some logic to try
to capture properties that were not
originally expressible in this work our
motivation is perhaps somewhat different
we wanted to try to come up with simple
logics that allowed for the direct
expression of efficient algorithms for
this counting problem and once again our
logics sort of balance out two
properties on the one hand we saw that
we couldn't affect Express sort of the
class of algorithms that we wanted to
but on the other hand we saw this sort
of good computability problem that we
could completely perform with
minimization and indeed this isn't a
property that we should take for granted
as the in positive first-order logic
with minimization is not computable okay
so I'd like to wrap up just by naming a
couple of open issues one is that we'd
like to perhaps try to understand better
express ability in our logic so one can
ask if there
to express a style games for for
characterizing accessibility in our
logic and finally in this work we
focused mostly on existential positive
formulas and sort of one can extend to
larger logics right so I can try that
for example proof classification
theorems for larger fragments of
first-order logic or thief or other
logics thank you very much just
confusing can you give an example then
you can count but not least right so if
the number of free variables is huge or
say linear the number of your number of
satisfying a sentence could be
exponential the size of the formula
right so I guess one has to maybe
specify what one means by list no but
how can you look how can you say there
are five without finding them imagine
that I give you the uniformly true
formula with with n free variables right
so in a structure of size two there will
be two to the N satisfying assignments
right it's easy to compute to to the end
given to an N right but but actually
list them would take exponential time an
end what kind of yeah if you have to
specify the model a general conceptually
I try to figure out what it means to do
you can say there are five people in
this room about it for Trump without
it does yet also counting them
the algorithm having to go visit them
but is the counter example is giving is
when the number is just very big I don't
know that he has an example in mind when
the number is small I don't like this
satisfactory but I think that I results
in the surface dichotomy version where
people have looked at the complexity of
counting I think armonk renew here they
are right and they're the only tractable
case is the fine cage right all right so
then also sorry for few seconds
dichotomy for counting the only
tractable cases is when you have systems
of linear equations disappear clean you
and karma but when you look they're also
crania with her blood have looked at the
enumeration for your polynomial delay
there I think it goes differently i
think it's only the call the dual core
that if you remember because all in fact
most of the tractable cases get an
example polynomial delay difficult rock
that's all I'm saying I your comment
that here I guess it's all so different
because like the counting you just want
to produce one number right so in fact
if you sort of dig into our proof
they're sort of like algebraic
cancellations so it might be easy to
sort of generate the number but hard to
actually lists all of the solutions hi
can you introduce but they do you have
an example ever maybe I'll get back to
you on that yen so i guess the though
they possibly similar question is you
mentioned using inclusion exclusion of
at some point if that's really needed
then I think it answers your question
because when use inclusion actually
you're really taking advantage of
accounting rather than making making
less effect studying that is how I guess
much a general question is it really
neat
could you have lived without conclusions
right thank you very much